wir stehen vor einem quantensprung der
computertechnologie unglaubliche 85
milliarden rechenoperationen pro sekunde
das entspricht der rechenleistung von
300.000 gewöhnlichen computern damit
sehe der jülicher supercomputer jubels
als einen meilenstein auf dem weg zum
ersten exascale rechner und das wäre
weltweit der nächste große schritt im
super computing click solutions im
future hier gibt's drei mal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
dieses video ist in zusammenarbeit mit
der redaktion von ix entstanden das
fachmagazin informiert über alle
wegweisende entwicklung im it-bereich
und am ende oder hier unterm und in der
video beschreibung und über ersten
kommentare könnt ihr euch eine digitale
ausgabe gratis sicher es sind
unvorstellbar enorme datenmengen die
täglich in den verschiedenen bereichen
von forschung und wissenschaft zusammen
kommen egal ob es um die strömungen der
atmosphäre geht die suche nach neuen
wirkstoffen oder aber die entwicklung
von kosmischen strukturen um solche
komplexen prozesse zu simulieren braucht
es supercomputer der schnellste
supercomputer europas läuft tatsächlich
in deutschland genau genommen in jülich
in nordrhein westfalen nach angaben der
fachleute erreicht der jubel
supercomputer 85 petaflops das heißt
also dass er achtung 85 milliarden
rechenoperationen pro sekunde durch und
somit ist der jüdischer supercomputer
auch der siebtschnellsten rechner auf
der ganzen welt doch es gibt ein
weiteres merkmal das ihnen von allen
anderen supercomputern dieser welt
abhebt dazu später mehr
für die forschung sind super computer
heutzutage unverzichtbar
dazu der bioinformatiker jan kobel daten
verdoppeln sich in der wissenschaft alle
18 monate
das ist die weltweite daten lange in der
wissenschaft in jedem feld das ist auch
ein trend der sich seit über zehn jahren
ständig fortsetzt ohne big data können
wir eigentlich gar keine komplexen
biologie mehr betreiben sind kleine
labore erzeugen daten in großem stil und
brauchen heutzutage computer
laut der aktuellen liste der 500
leistungsfähigsten supercomputer der
welt belegt deutschland die plätze 7 15
und 16
am start sind die rechner des deutschen
gauss centre for supercomputing in
jülich münchen und stuttgart die vom
bund und den jeweiligen bundesländern
gemeinsam finanziert werden die top 500
liste wird einmal im jahr in den usa
veröffentlicht und zwar bei der
supercomputer konferenz der association
for computing machinery und der computer
society hierbei werden die systeme in
hinblick auf ihre rechenleistung das
betriebssystem ihre hardware kennzahlen
und andere faktoren verglichen klar ist
supercomputer sind ganz besonders
schneller rechner zudem sind sie
besonders groß und die hardware die
verbaut wird hat es wirklich in sich der
erste erfolgreiche architekt eines
supercomputers was sie mag ray der scc
6600 entworfen hatte 964 sollte dieser
zehnmal so schnell rechnen wie andere
computer dieser zeit seitdem hat sich
der aufbau der supercomputer viel getan
allerdings gehören die quantencomputer
nicht dazu denn die haben zwar eine
weitaus größere rechenleistung zumindest
ermöglichen sie die aber dazu müssten
sie über das bisherige experimental
stadium hinaus kommen fachleute gehen
davon aus dass das erst in zehn bis 15
jahren so weit sein wird und so
konzentrieren sich viele bereiche weiter
auf die supercomputer zu der aktuellen
top500 liste der supercomputer sagt
bundesforschungsministerin anja
karliczek von der cdu in einem interview
mit dem handelsblatt deutschland spielt
in der weltliga der supercomputer mit
demnach sein zitat superschnelle rechner
eine absolute zukunftstechnologie im
digitalzeitalter der aufbau von
hochleistungsrechnern zählt also zu
einem unverzichtbaren baustein der
hightech strategie der deutschen
bundesregierung erst vor einigen monaten
fertig gestellt und schon jetzt auf
platz 7 der liste der schnellste
supercomputer europas im
forschungszentrum jülich das google
system hat eben die 85 milliarden
rechenoperationen pro sekunde was er
300.000 modernen computern entspricht
was dazu kommt bei diesem deutschen
supercomputer handelt es sich um das
energieeffizienz system in der höchsten
leistungsklasse
doch wie ist das möglich
laut der fachleute liegt es vor allem an
der flexiblen kombination von
prozessoren und grafik prozessoren
dazu bernhard frohwitter der an der
entwicklung des systems beteiligt waren
der clou bei jubels ist das kleine
module das bisherige cluster modul das
mit schnellen prozessoren cpu s arbeitet
und das brewster module mit seinen
grafikprozessoren ganz eng verschaltet
sind im klartext heißt das also dass
juhls dadurch innerhalb eines codes
dynamisch auf cpu und gpu zugreifen kann
also auf computer prozessoren und grafik
prozessoren und so die rechnung
optimieren kann
das neue poster modul ist mit seinen
leistungsstarken hocheffizienten
grafikprozessoren speziell für die
ausgesprochen rechenintensiven
anwendungen ausgelegt die sich gut
parallel auf einer großen zahl von
rechenkern bearbeiten lassen
so erreicht der booster nach angaben der
fachleute alleine eine spitzenleistung
von 73 petaflops vor allem bei
anwendungen aus dem bereich der
künstlichen intelligenz kann er das
sogar noch toppen wir sind sogar bis zu
2,5 exaflop es möglich das entspricht
achtung 2,5 billionen rechenoperationen
pro sekunde also absolut wahnsinnige
zahlen und damit und das ist das absolut
bemerkenswerte können unglaublich
komplexe aufgaben gelöst werden mit
jedem supercomputer und jedem
fortschritt dort dringen wir in neue
dimensionen des wissensforums kam hirn
atlanten errechnen neuronale netzwerke
simulieren also künstliche intelligenz
mit einer unglaublichen rechenpower
betreiben den klimawandel modellieren
und prognostizieren und und und
höchstleistungsrechner wie jewels
blicken in die zukunft so
bundesforschungsminister anja karliczek
bei der einweihung und dies kann noch
mehr komplexe konstruktion und auch
astronomie physik oder chemie
die forschung die mit hilfe von googles
möglich ist ist sehr praxisnah
so kann die medikamentenentwicklung in
der aktuellen co at 19 krise unterstützt
werden die rechenpower des boosters
simuliert dabei diejenigen prozesse die
ablaufen wenn ein potentieller wirkstoff
auf einen rezeptor oder protein trifft
und das sehr realitätsnah bei solch
einer gigantischen rechenleistung müsste
man einen enormen energieverbrauch
vermuten doch das augenmerk der
fachleute lag bei der entwicklung des
jubels supercomputers vor allem auf
maximaler energieeffizienz und so hat
sich djuric auf der aktuellen green500
liste sogar platz drei gesichert und das
ist das energieeffizienteste system in
der höchsten leistungsklasse
möglich wird diese energieeffizienz vor
allem durch zwei besonderheiten zum
einen durch die effiziente
arbeitsteilung innerhalb des systems und
zum anderen durch eine direkte wasser
kühlung der prozessoren
diese ist deutlich effizienter als
kühlung durch lüfter wie sonst üblich
ist dazu der vorstandsvorsitzende des
forschungszentrums jülich wolfgang
marquardt wir verstehen super computing
nicht nur als gegenstand unserer
forschung sondern vor allem auch als
mächtiges werkzeug mit dem wir gemeinsam
mit unseren partnern aus wissenschaft
und industrie komplexe forschungs
fragestellungen beantworten können
gleichzeitig demonstrieren wir mit dem
system aber auch den
verantwortungsvollen umgang mit dem
immer weiter zunehmenden energiebedarf
für die bereitstellung von
rechenleistung der dschungel
supercomputer und seine platzierung in
der top500-liste ist ein riesenerfolg
für die jüdischer wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler doch die fachleute
sehen noch viel mehr in ihm einen
meilenstein hin zum europäischen
exascale rechner
das sind noch mal schneller
supercomputer zehn bis zwanzigmal
nochmals schneller als heutige
supercomputer und dieser extras geld
rechner soll schon in zwei jahren also
ab dem jahr 2023 an den start gehen
angepeilt wird dann eine rechenleistung
von achtung einer trillion
gleitkommaoperationen pro sekunde
das wäre also der nächste große schritt
in sachen super computing damit wäre er
noch einmal mindestens zwölfmal
schneller als juwel selbst dazu thomas
lippert jubels modulare architektur das
design seiner rechenknoten das netzwerk
die infrastruktur und die kühlung sowie
die software architektur lassen sich
ohne weiteres auf einen extra scale
rechner übertragen wobei kosten und
energieaufwand vertretbar bleiben und
eine weitere hoffnung haben die
jüdischer forschungsteams sie wolle
newell's auch mit anderen zukunfts
technologien verbinden sie denken dabei
zb an quantencomputer module und an euro
für module die nach dem vorbild des
menschlichen gehirns arbeiten
mehr zum thema und anderen
umfassend recherchierten themen aus dem
bereich erfahrt ihr im fachmagazin ix
von it security über big data bis hin zu
embedded systems exklusiv für euch
klicks umzuschauen de gibt es jetzt eine
digitale ausgabe gratis ging dafür
einfach hier auf diesen link oder unten
in der video beschreibung oder auf den
ersten kommentar es lohnt sich auf jeden
fall also anklicken anschauen und dann
das gratis herunterladen bis dann bleibt
dran